welcome to this video motzko plush i
don't know that i have no no way to
pronounce that so we have some Queen
pawn opening he usually play some kinda
place the snake benoni but i wanted to
something else here he likes us weird
move so maybe like 95 year maybe for
quincy form or something like that
something active if f6 is playable of
course
then I'm going back no you can also just
castle I guess
well it irritates them at least yeah
just castling is good mmm this is a bit
more ambitious let's say let's go here
hmm therefore movers that we had and it
someone to be it but why not
hmm can you do something really crazy
like 94 takes but should be four check
no I don't think so
um kind of happy that you took one T
phone it looks like it helped my ascent
the summer take on g6 Bishop 33 years
something simple to play you can
definitely go all out ninety seven or so
okay interesting so let's say that I can
take with the f corner oh we are okay
come on let's do something crazy
hmm at least it irritates him I don't
know mmm dad that's a good move trying
for a five year mmm yeah
may be still and know we have my going
property back here h6 in the bishop H
form yeah I think I have to take this
here my development is really really bad
this really bad
okay before I have c4 it's not super
dangerous try and look h3g three this
kind of thing but ok here cook age three
and g3 can go push a page from that's
not really on ok again before I have c4
it's not a huge problem so prepared you
for like that maybe I know it looks very
strange but currently my rook is not
doing much but Bishop on f1 is kind of
on the diagonal where it wants to be oh
wow
hmm I and I understand he wants to go
before this one first
a five maybe I can take 50 min k
preventing that so let's go let's go
g-form trying for some kind of concrete
counter play so takes bishop age 6
Bishop f8 yeah maybe I have to do this
now get rid of that Bishop there if he
goes before I take f5 and i have e 6
then Bishop g5 yep push-up 86 Bishop f8
Bishop g7 bishops you share with age age
6 is an idea so take your first so the a
file is opened
really hope that's not too slow those
pawns are quite dangerous be takes III
left resins III root g7 and it doesn't
have the time to doesn't have the time
to do it I really don't know that was
probably bad for me but I just felt like
doing something out of the ordinary with
this this kind of play incoming
challenge there that must be good for
him somehow but the computer is actually
not that convinced just gives him a
slight edge with Bishop e7 however yeah
yeah I really didn't know I mean engine
is on equal I hear Bishop edge for seems
to be good I mean I saw the move but
Chad what I just go here what is the
problem Oh before is killing me
immediately pin this is the problem this
bow checkmate yeah and I have to look
before i don't really i cannot cover
yeah this is check also disastrous whoa
wow ok bishop edge for was very good
then one problem shattuck this is
answered by f1 community group evade
very tough
and yet here I'm actually okay again and
here even now ok computer wants to do
this and then this move male yeah this
is very strong where you have very sharp
stuff objectively maybe it maybe it
somehow holds for him Bishop 26 text x
bouquet 7 group g8 might still hold and
I think only somewhere here after this
is probably video one yeah lamb after
this yeah thought route class level
isn't it isn't that clear actually and
I'm not wrong with that check this is
actually given as equal by the engine
yeah so computer actually I'm not quite
sure I should think I probably would
have done that computer wants to do this
and go for Shaq check this thing and
that wins the winning end game but yeah
I think he resides I mean okay yet also
no time on the clock probably lose him
on time in any case but I probably
should have tried that i'm not sure i
think i probably would have gone for the
window the Queen just to have it in the
back but that end game didn't didn't
look Leah at all okay thanks for
watching